Chris Waters here on the gam spot stage
joined by Sha Velasco captain of yach
Club games that's right it says it on
his business card you're the captain uh
yeah I mean we don't really do titles
too much at the Yacht Club there's only
about half a dozen of us and we just
wear so many hats but uh so we all just
kind of came up with like fictional
boating titles and now that's what's on
our business Captain's a pretty good one
uh captain of development on shovel kns
this is the game you guys are here
showing off at San Diego ComicCon and
released actually recently on the steam
yes yeah I mean that's right we came out
June 26th and uh you know on Steam and
also on the Wii U and on the 3DS and uh
so this is the first time that we've
seen people that have actually gotten
their hands on the game finished the
game played the full thing and now
they're coming to us at the booth and
you know talking about it uh I mean the
response has just been completely
overwhelming have you seen any Shovel
Knight cosplay yet uh we saw pictures of
one but I haven't seen anyone at ComiCon
yet okay there it does exist and
actually there's a you guys there's a
figure fine as well I think we have a
shot
of out there there he is the the Shovel
Knight right yes yeah that's a that's a
vinyl figure that's being made by uh pop
culture shock toys and so that's the
mockup I I've only seen the 3D model and
so this is like the real one that's
actually there uh I I desperately want
to get my hands I mean you got to get
one right yeah yeah I I want the whole
lineup I mean I want the I want the
shovel nut I want the whole order of No
Quarter like we you know we want to do a
lot of stuff like that I'd love to see
like a Shovel Knight like shampoo bottle
where you screwed the head off you know
or or like a like you want full
merch yes I want breakfast cereal I want
I want pajamas like I want Shovel Knight
textiles like everything that's I mean
it sounds like you got got a whole
catalog in mind all right well we got
the game here on Steam we're going to uh
be I'll be playing it a little bit uh
while we sort of talk about uh I guess
you know talk about the basics of shovel
knighte for folks who uh are not not yet
versed all right well uh Shovel Knight
is basically an 8bit love letter to the
NES games of the past you know as you
can see it's obviously very
aesthetically similar to those games but
we tried to just take those games as a
starting point and then kind of evolve
everything uh as you go so Shovel Knight
was planned as a game that was going to
be built off of a singular mechanic like
shovelin exactly just like all the great
NES games right it's like you know with
Mario you have you have a jump it's like
with Metroid you have a ball right and
with Shovel Knight you have a shovel and
got that one thing right and those
really well yes those
mechanics they inform the entire game so
we thought okay well let's make a game
about like a about like a down thrust
about a downward stabbing move that you
could use to defeat enemies and then we
started thinking well what else could we
do with this right like maybe this
Implement is flipping enemies over maybe
it's digging up treasure maybe we're
talking about a shovel and then you know
we realized we realized we were talking
about a shov all just circling this one
idea it turned out to be a shovel right
and so from that we built out everything
else right the idea that he was a knight
uh the the rest of the story and the
rest of the characters and also the rest
of the mechanics I think that's my
favorite enemy by the way just the rat
dangling from a helicopter like not
doesn't really even appear to be that
Sinister like not maybe not sure why who
pitched the rat up to the hel the
helicopter but going to do it anyways
right yeah I mean they're not even evil
they're just kind of coming at you just
kind of there yeah so the stage that
you're playing right now Pride more keep
this is the St that we had taken around
to like P and to uh we went to mine con
actually which was which was completely
crazy because unlike a Pax or unlike a
Comic-Con everyone is you know under 4
and 1/2 ft tall and it's all it's all
these kids and so we had kids playing
Shovel Knight uh that was another big
thing that we that we were a little bit
worried about right I mean cuz you know
are you worried that they're not sort of
getting the the reference exactly right
like that Nostalgia just wasn't going to
play in
but what we found is that as soon as
they picked up the game it was kind of
well like the same way that that I was
okay now be careful here this checkpoint
uh it has money inside it if you break
it then it stops working as a checkpoint
but I get money yeah but you get money
well given that my life is at half
already I think for the sake of demo
we're going with uh checkpoint yes
that's probably probably a smart idea
and look there's something there too oh
my gosh secret time yeah so it it's like
once people picked up the game and
actually got a chance to play it uh you
know even even younger kids or people
that didn't have Nostalgia for for 8bit
games or for the NES uh you know I know
a lot of people in the UK they played
like you know like like Sinclair or like
Spectrum like computer games and so they
don't have the same kind of nostalgia
but they' really been enjoying the game
too so cool yeah it's just been uh it's
been pretty overwhelming and wonderful
neat all right so you guys you know
you're showing it but you're at the
you're not on the show floor here at
Comic-Con you're at the Nintendo Booth
which is in a separate Hotel venue yeah
that's right it's right outside of
Comic-Con uh at the Marriott and so
there is a large show presence and
they're I mean they're mostly showing
off Smash Brothers of course uh and
they're doing like a raffle and they're
giving out t-shirts and everything and
yeah there are two uh there are two
Shovel Knight 3Ds kiosks and one Shovel
Knight Wii U kiosk so we we're just
there on the floor talking to everybody
and kind of just of course that was
going to happen a chandeliers you can
never trust them crown delers
CR delers what are you call them well
yeah well okay so this was yeah this was
another ridiculous thing I mean we do so
much goofing around when we're making a
game like this as you can imagine
because it's it's just ends up being so
silly and so these were the chandeliers
that end up falling on you but because
it's in Pride more keep and because it's
King Knight and he's opulent and
decadent then he has Crown delers oh he
made his chandeliers out of crowns
because otherwise how they would not
appreciate his majesty all right this
looks difficult I don't know if I'm
going to be able to accomplish this uh
give it a shot careful
careful y did it there that wasn't so
bad then I solve the puzzle by standing
here that oh nice looks like it was made
for
you it was my destiny all
along grounders uh so let's talk about
the 3DS and the Wii U versions because
oh wait hold on Chester what wow wow
it's a weird place for you to be hanging
out
Chester you're not going to believe what
I just found in this chest yeah you
should totally get that conjure fiery
beasts yes I will definitely conjure
fiery beasts hold up and press X got a
magic meter yeah yeah so you can see
over there the magic wand is now on near
your item and you have 30 magic so every
time you shoot that wand it's going to
take some of your magic but it's an
extremely useful weapon to have for a
short range hero like Shovel
Knight and this is just kind of like a
little secret path that's another thing
that we wanted to do is like these kinds
of games like like it be games were
filled with secrets and lots of
alternate things to
do just walk directly into a pit it's
okay son of a do I keep my magic wand
thing yes you do keep the magic wand but
as you saw you dropped some money uh
that that flew out in bags right that's
your loot and you can go back and Sh
Knight you know for all of his sort of
uh diligent emphasis on shoveling is all
about the loot like he's chasing those
gems like crazy yeah the the shovel
Knight's greed wasn't something that we
were really planning on when we were
developing the game but it's like when
you play it it's like wow I really am
all I'm doing is collecting money he
seems like almost like a Wario esque
character with just all about the cash
he's all about it but then and then so
uh you know this is such it's such a
natural fit for a controller so of
course you know on the the d-pad of the
3DS or of the the Wii U you're going to
going to fit really well but those
systems also sort of have uh you know
their own little unique yes you Hardware
elements that you can take advantage of
or not uh so what was your approach to
that for well I mean we wanted to make
sure that with every version of the game
that there was something that was at
least a little bit cool to differentiate
it from the others but for the main part
it was just one basic experience that
that's the same for everyone so we
didn't want to add anything that was too
crazy or too out there okay so for the
3DS first off we have stereoscopic
presentation which is it looks just
incredible it's like you know face
melting 3D that's just way awesome uhhuh
and then it melts your face off like all
awesome things
do and then on top of that we're also
supporting the street pass Arena uh
which is like a basically you record a
5-second loop of yourself playing in an
arena in a single screen Arena
environment and then another player does
that same thing and when you Street pass
it runs the battles against each other
so it's kind of like a random it's like
a random battle but you can have a
little bit of strategy so you choose
your battle actions without knowing what
your opponent's going to do yes yes uh
reminds me of like frozen synapse is a
that does that and so I mean do that
that thing is I imagine that's the kind
of thing you have to do a lot of testing
on and you know try to oh hello yeah
well it was it was you guys have fun
have a lot of fun with that just kind of
messing around yes of course and we and
in addition to playing as just the
development team we also like to bring
in people right like we'll bring in
friends that uh that are interested in
games or maybe people that don't know a
lot about games either and just kind of
see how everyone reacts to it um yeah so
the street passerina was great fun and
just as I've been walking around San
Diego ComicCon I've seen or or or I've
gotten like you know 10 or 12 Shovel
Knight Street passes oh really in Shovel
Knight alone yes and that's just that's
insane uh and and wonderful so that's
the 3DS version but for the for the we U
version we have this thing called the
diggers diary and it uses the meerse
functionality of the Wii U the the
meerse for for those of you that don't
know it's just like a it's almost like a
social network but it's only for
Nintendo so and you and all you do is
talk about games yeah and you just post
on it's like a forum posting almost yeah
yeah you post screenshots you can you
can do little drawings oh that was so
close thought he was going to knock you
off I was going to get a rat in the face
yeah cuz there's like a little knockback
too to most when you take damage right
yes yeah you get knocked back and then
you can get knocked right back into a
pit uh but if you're turning the other
way and you get hit then you can kind of
use that as like to your advantage you
that's a speedr running technique of
damage boosting that's oh like jumping
on the other side of an enemy and taking
a hit so you get like a few frames
further yeah exactly now you mentioned
speed running I we we'll get to the Wii
U Meer stuff again real quick but I want
to I just want to mention uh speedr
running has such a phenomenon that's
sort of On The Rise especially with uh
twitch and uh these sort of um like like
awesome games live yeah these live
streaming fundraisers like awesome Games
Done Quick if you guys did you design
the game specifically with like that
kind of uh ability in mind like we want
people to be able to do this with our
game we want there to be these sort of
exploits the people who are dedicated
find and find ways to to eek it out yes
we we definitely did that I mean with
Shovel Knight we actually sent the game
off like I was saying we we gave it to
kind of friends and and people that were
close to us for evaluation and some of
those people were speedrunners so we
gave speedrunners the game and we said
hey what is you know what's weird about
this that would make it so you don't
want to speedrun it uh like for instance
speedr Runners hate when there's too
much random generation for everything
because it makes it too unpredictable
and it's almost like where the enemy is
going to be specifically or anything
like that if it could kill your run if
if some Randomness could kill your
entire run then it's like that's a game
that maybe you don't want to run CU it
just wouldn't be it wouldn't be worth it
yeah right yeah you couldn't couldn't
sort of do the the due d and study it
enough to feel like you're enough of a
master right so yeah so we had them uh
we had them give comments like that and
we made some changes there are some
things that we didn't uh get the chance
to include like for instance a lot of
speedrunners would appreciate having a
clock like a like a an accurate Real
Time game clock that's on the screen at
all times sure uh but that's the kind of
stuff that we're going to be probably be
able to put into patches and future
updates for all of the I mean for all
the versions of Shovel Knight okay
working this out here yeah I don't think
you can shovel down on that oh I can oh
there oh no yeah so once again like this
is another thing that's like learning
through doing Shovel Knight is a game
that doesn't have a lot of tutorials it
doesn't have a lot of uh of explanation
it kind of gives you your things that
you can do and then just sets you free
in the environment to to play As You
Wish mhm and now I've also like I've
gone off to the right here pretty
significantly okay oh I hit it I got to
I could hit down on it and pop up all
right I went off to the right there but
there was an area off to the left that I
you know maybe should like are there are
there like this area right here actually
I guess I'll go in here this is a
question like is there just one ending
to the level and so this is like a loop
that I'm going to go through and come
back or yes yeah that's exactly how it
works okay so these are secrets that you
know you want to get that oh nicely done
wow yeah you'll go on a little offshoot
Loop like this and it'll always bring
you back to where you were uh
occasionally you can cut off some of the
path but that's very very few in far
between okay yeah you know Sean you had
me play this game for the demo to make
it a little easier for you to talk what
you didn't anticipate was the stress of
watching someone else play your game and
maybe uh not do super well well you know
I have watched a lot of people play pack
demos and uh ComicCon demos and I'm
doing super well is what you're and
you're doing great yeah you're doing
great nope the lava oh it was so close
this is and this is uh this is so
wonderful because this is is our this
was our packs demo this is our demo that
show floor goers would see every time
and just like how you are they would die
on this spot a few times a few times
they got the the magic books figured out
we would have a crowd of people behind
us kind of just like you know we're like
oh when everyone was dying and it's just
like like that sort of group uh I don't
know just the group involvement in a
game like that where we're all kind of
cheering on something it's so much it's
so much
fun uh so let's say I you know I'm
playing this on the Wii U this part is
super vexing me I take a screenshot I
share it with the meerse is that kind of
what you guys had in mind well right so
basically the way that it works on the
Wii U is the game pad acts as well the
feature is called the Digger diary so so
the meerse uh two messages will appear
and they'll pertain to whatever room
that you're currently standing in so it
would say something along the lines of
like oh watch out for these cauldrons
here or like make sure to down thrust on
this book or or you know whatever the
case may be right or watch out for the
rat those dang propeller rats right or
like sometimes you'll get a meie post
that's just like scribbling on the
screen because whoever it was was just
so angry about it and so it it's cool
you can commiserate with other people
that are having a rough time you can get
hints if you don't kind of know where
you're going or people are also just
being so creative drawing pictures of
Shovel Knight and of the characters a
and uh you know once again just the
entire team is pouring through that
stuff every day yeah loving it laughing
emails and different stuff yeah well
it's the beauty of it is we're all in
the same room you know so it doesn't
even need to be a company email you got
a down thrust on it man I know the I
know the component parts skull is like
right here it's just execution and it
doesn't help that the production team is
yelling is laughing at me with every
death freaking jerks all right so uh
Shovel Knight a game not without its
challenge uh you know and that's sort of
in the spirit of its inspiration I guess
is those those sort of these old school
games not they're not making things
super easy for you they want you to have
to work for it a little bit yes and that
was one of our goals from the from the
get-go really was we wanted to make a
game that was beatable by by pretty much
anyone as long as they put their mind to
it for long enough right and where maybe
weren't didn't have any distractions
like lights shining face people talking
to them right yeah you're not shooting
video at the same time I'm going to do a
shot yeah we having a conversation right
like when I'm like when I'm playing the
game I just need total concentration I
found that after even after maybe a
couple hours or 3 hours of playing you
know when you're playing a real intense
game it's like you just have to set it
down start to lose your Edge yeah
everything just goes downhill I thought
I had another jump off that platform
that time so I but you can all right so
this is the thing that I think I might
be missing I don't have to wait for the
book to close before bouncing on it
again and resetting the the like
platform timer every time you do it it
will refresh it yeah okay okay all right
so uh you know the Digger diary
certainly something that could maybe
give people a hand uh if they're having
a little trouble with it uh that's only
on the Wii U version you guys have uh
different difficulty levels uh like
maybe Dam they affect damage or
something like that well there aren't
exactly difficulty levels but all the
you know all the treasure that your
greedy Shovel Knight is scooping up
throughout the entire stage can be taken
back into a village and you can use that
Village to upgrade yourself okay so
right now you only have four life but
you could go and you can maximize your
life so it extends you know almost all
the way out to the boss meter uh you
know you picked up oh God God God made
it yeah wonderful oh that was so
good and then I'm going to clob by a
chandelier under turkey everything's
fine everything's fine Crown aier sorry
yeah so you can get more you can
increase your magic you can uh you can
get different sub weapons or different
relics that you couldn't necessarily get
in the stages and you can also upgrade
your shovel you can get more armor and
none of these things are like none of
them are going to help you if you're
falling into pits sure uh but they can
really help augment what you're doing uh
so you can play it more in the way that
you're prepared to okay uh like for
instance in a like in Mega Man 2 is the
game that I that I just keep thinking of
you have item one two and three and each
of those items is like a it's almost
like a little cheat right like one of
them is like a jet that let you go
across gaps one of them like let you
climb up the walls and uh and then the
last one is like a little it's just like
a little puffy platform oh here's King
Knight King Knight an intop is in our
midst begone from our Throne Room Nave
I'm not going to voice the whole thing
I'm no more an intruder than you you
aren't even a real
king oh but you're mistaken the
enchantress saw me for my fabulously
Regal self and now all bow before me
you're not but a decadent
Dandy prepare to taste Justice shovel
Justice
silence yes that was beautiful I can't
wait till the voice acted of this game
oh God this shovel Justice is not going
well for me I'm shoot some magic yeah I
remembered that I had that good good you
got four shots left on it that was three
ow oh he does the high jump so this is
and this is also the sort of uh this
probably I don't want to get hit by the
confetti yeah that is razor sharp
confetti so someone did uh shaming
pictures of all of the bosses so there's
boss shaming pictures on the internet
and it's it's King night me sitting
there holding a sign that says I put
glass in the
confetti so brilliant that's good yeah
all right uh I am probably not going to
take another shot at King Knight here uh
maybe one more but uh so this game is it
is it it's available on Steam is it
currently out on 3DS and Wii U oh yeah
yeah yeah all yeah it's out on Wii U and
3DS eShop uh and that's in North America
and the steam version is international
okay yeah we're working on the EU
localization right now um and you know
we we love to have all sorts of crazy
announcements of all the crazy things
that shovel Knight's going to be doing
very soon uh if you I mean if you you
know if you're doing some some new Voice
work for the EU version then uh I mean
I'm available you're
available my shovel night skills may not
be up to par but I like to think I can
lend some gravitas to the shoveling yeah
I mean that was truly excellent acting
Sean thank you so much for coming by
showing off some shovel KN folks you can
get this game now on the platform Sean
mentioned Wii U 3DS and PC and uh I hope
you have a great show showing it off to
folks here yeah thank you very much all
right take it easy folks shovel Knights
out
now